okay so thank you for the question what
I was talking about was for those of you
who are not part of the conversation I
was in Denmark and a young girl who was
16 said that her mom told her that she
wasn't Muslim when we asked her why she
said look at me when we looked at her
nobody could figure out what she was
talking about and then she pointed to
what she was wearing which was jeans and
a t-shirt and this Imam had been trained
outside of Denmark and actually didn't
speak Danish and really brought his
understanding of Islam from his village
and Morocco to Denmark that's really not
helpful to a 16 year old kid who's
growing up in Copenhagen the issues of a
mom training and I'm putting that in
quotes because it's a terrible
terminology and nobody seems to be able
to figure out a better one is really
complex because you have countries all
across Europe that do things in
different ways in Germany for example
they've turned it over to the Turks so
the Turks basically pick their Imams the
government of Turkey picks their mom
sons limited Germany and there's really
no vetting that goes on it's the Turkish
government that picks that you have
other countries in Europe who allow
people who to learn about Islam by going
to other countries and come back and
then preach there's no standard within a
lot of Muslim communities of what it
means to be an in mom and then you have
second and third and fourth generations
in some places who don't understand the
distillation of what it means to be an
imam because in Islam there is no
hierarchy of like Christianity where you
know a cardinal a bishop you know our
priest or a minister and it's a very
different kind of thing in a mom is
somebody who is a learned person and
it's also somebody who leads the prayer
so when you have societies and
communities that don't know enough about
the religion they're looking to sources
that can validate their understanding or
their belief if you happy moms that
don't understand what I was specifically
talking about Europe European history or
speak European languages it's really
hard to talk to a young generation how
do you how do you how do you help that
person navigate through the identities
what is the role of government they're
really careful okay what we might my
belief is that the government as I
I'm going to use this term another time
the convener the facilitator and the
intellectual partner with NGOs and other
organic and credible partners in those
countries that can actually help
facilitate some of this a government
can't train a religious leader a
government can't give a check mark and
say that's a pure Muslim and that's not
up here Muslim I mean that's absurd but
what you can do is you can help
strengthen the way in which communities
understand what's going on and the
government's can in fact let ease up on
some of the local laws that are
preventing people from being trained
within within their countries
interestingly France for example has a
university in Paris which is a I think
it's Cameron the name i'm sorry i'm
getting going blank but it's
predominantly a christian theology
university that has a training course
for Muslims to learn about Islam and
they can then become Imams the
University of Laden in Holland does the
same thing there are five or six
different programs around Europe in
which they've tried to figure out how to
make somebody in a mom by giving them
like a when your course or to your
course which is not exactly the best way
of doing getting to the issues that they
need to get to but it's how government
is actually helping to try to figure out
how to solve those key issues what I do
know is that you could think about an
institution like al-azhar which is one
of the oldest institutions for a sum in
the world and outside of Cairo and sorry
it's in car and think well does Europe
need the equivalent of and all eyes are
where European Muslims themselves can be
trained by Europeans to talk about these
things as this conversation is happening
in Oxford this conversation is happening
and and in various other parts of Europe
because they're trying to drive drive
answers government comes in through
funding and government can come in
through promoting that conversation